IDE fix auf Mars missission im Universum
des Nachbarplaneten ein
Abendteuer als kleiner Passagier auf
einem japanischen Raumschiff soll er
sich auf die Reise zum Marsmond fobus
machen er geht auf eine sehr sage ich
mal gefährliche Reise er landet in einer
sehr unwrdlichen Gegend der spannendste
Augenblick wird tatsächlich sein wenn
der auf dem Marsmond frobus landen wird
wäre Idefix ein echter Hund würde er
dort nicht überleben können
edefix ist ein kleiner Rover er trägt
nur den Namen eines berühmten
komikhelden ich kenne die astrix und
Obelix Comics und da ist der idifix der
kleine Hund der überall mit herumstrom
hat und Sachen entdeckt und das wäre für
mich dieser Rover also es ist ein
kleiner Begleiter der neugierig ist und
bereit ist Sachen zu entdecken wir haben
ganz wenig Energie der arme ideefix
sozusagen ist ein Hund der wirklich da
auf auf Diät gesetzt ist auf aber auf
eine extremdiät gefüttert wird er mit
Sonnenstrahlung aber da er klein ist und
nur kleine Solarzellen hat und dadurch
dass wir sow weit weg sind von der Sonne
kriegen wir nur ganz wenig Strahlung und
dadurch ist Idefix eben auf Magerkost
gesetzt wir haben dem Idefix seine
wissenschaftlichen Augen und Ohren
gegeben ein kleiner vierbeiniger Roboter
der es uns ermöglicht auf der Oberfläche
mobil den frus zu erkunden der Name IDE
fix kommt eigentlich aus dem
französischen IDE fix ein
ja und steht eigentlich für eine gewisse
Sturheit aber auch Zielstrebigkeit und
aus meiner Sicht steht es eigentlich
sehr gut für dieses Team und man braucht
auch eine gewisse Zielstrebigkeit um das
durchzuziehen und dafür steht dieser
kleine Hund
idifix um Idefix zu entwickeln hatte das
Team von projektliter Markus Grebenstein
nur 4 Jahre Zeit der 25 kg leichte Rover
aus Carbon ist etwa so groß und schwer
wie eine Getränkekiste die vier Beine
mit den großen Schaufelrädern waren die
größte Herausforderung für das Team der
Grund die extrem geringe Gravitation auf
fobus von lediglich einem zweitausendel
der Erdanziehung hier wiegt Idefix dann
nur noch so viel wie ein
Briefumschlag um nicht abzuheben kann er
sich nur sehr langsam zunächst nur einen
millm pro Sekunde auf dem phobusboden
fortbewegen es kann sein dass dieser
Boden sich benimmt wie Pulverschnee dann
werden wir mit unseren dann eher
schaufelnd durch über den Boden bewegen
oder es kann auch sein dass es eher wie
so ein Betonboden ist dann wird es
relativ holpernd sein edefix wäre der
erste Rover im Universum der sich auf so
einem kleinen Himmelskörper bewegt mit
klarer Mission eine Probe aus dem
marssystem auf die Erde zu bekommen um
rauszufinden ob es auf dem Mars Leben
gegeben hat und wie das ausgesehen hat
das Ziel für uns ist erstmalig auf fobos
zu landen und dort auf einem Körper mit
sehr sehr niedriger Schwerkraft zu
fahren und nachzuweisen das diese
Technologien dort funktionieren der Mond
phobus ein spannender
Himmelskörper fobos ist erstmal ein sehr
kleiner Körper ne der sehr nahe am Maß
oder den Maß umkreist er hat eine sehr
geringe Dichte und ihn zeichnen
verschiedene Oberflächenmerkmale viele
Krater viele Rillen aus man erwartet
dass die Oberfläche mit einer
Staubschicht bedeckt istos wird auch
manchmal liebevoll sozusagen eine kine
eine Kartoffel genannt ne klein auch
weil die Radien sehr klein sind also die
Größe von Berlin würde das Abdecken das
sind also 30 km im im Durchmesser der
längsten Achse viele Missionen haben den
Mars mit seinen beiden Monden phobus und
daamus bereits besucht die europäische
Mission Mars Express liefert seit 20
Jahren Daten zur Geologie und
Klimageschichte des roten Planeten dass
es Wasser auf unserem Nachbarn gab ist
sehr wahrscheinlich große Grabensysteme
geben verblüff Einblicke in seine
Geschichte auf dem Maß sind etliche
Einschläge passiert auch große
Einschläge und da ist erwartet dass sich
die der Auswurf dieser Impakte auch bis
zum phobus ausgebreitet haben so dass
fobus also durch diese Wolke des
maßmaterials durchgeflogen ist und es
aufgesammelt hat man möchte wissen was
für Gesteine sind dort dann weiß man
relativ sicher wo kommt der Mond
überhaupt her ist es ein eingefangener
Körper oder ist es ein rausgebr Stück
aus dem Mars dann gibt es uns relativ
wahrscheinlich Aufschluss darüber gab's
Leben wann gab's Leben und wo kommt das
Leben her letztendlich ist mal auf der
Suche nach Aminosäuren den
Grundbausteinen des Lebens eine
spannende Mission für idfix der ins
marsuniversum nicht alleine fliegt
sondern an Bord eines Raumschiffes der
japanischen Raumfahrtbehörde Jaxa
Herausforderungen muss ja viele Meistern
der erste Augenblick wo wir die Daumen
drücken ist der Start und in dem
Augenblick wo der Start abgeschlossen
ist wird sich Idefix in eine Erdumlauf
Bahn einschwenken und dort ein
Vierteljahr verbleiben und in diesem
Vierteljahr kann er schon erste
Rückmeldung
geben dann wird er eine längere Reise
von ca halben Jahr dreiviertel Jahr
antreten und auf den Maß einschwenken
und auch während des Fluges dorthin wird
es immer so sein dass wir Kontakt mit
ihnen
halten wird so aussehen dass wir in die
Umlaufbahn des fobos einschwenken werden
dann wird Jaxa einen probeanflug machen
um ihre eigene Landung vorzubereiten und
während dieses probeanflugs werden wir
dann auf einer Höhe von 30 bis 45 m vom
Raumschiff runtergeworfen werden dann so
60 bis 70 Sekunden fliegen die
Schwerkraft auf fobos ist ja sehr gering
das heißt wir werden nicht so wahnsinnig
schnell aufschlagen aber doch
aufschlagen auf der Oberfläche von fobos
werden dann über die Oberfläche Rollen
in einer beliebigen Lage zum Liegen
kommen und aus dieser Lage müssen wir
uns
aufrichten nachdem sich idfix so
kopfüber ins Abenteuer gestürzt hat wird
er hoffentlich genug Energie haben seine
vier filigranen Beine auszustrecken und
auf dem Fremden fernen Mond
[Musik]
aufzustehen dann wird der Rover in in
eine Grundstellung gehen wird seine
Solarpanele ausklappen damit er Energie
erzeugen kann diese Energie braucht er
dringend vor der ersten fobosnacht weil
er sonst so kalt wird dass die Batterien
nicht mehr funktionieren die Elektronik
nicht mehr funktioniert man muss sich
vorstellen der Tag dauert 7 Stunden auf
fobos und die Temperaturen gehen während
dieser 7 Stunden von -170 bis + 50° rauf
und wie runter das heißt das ganze wird
sehr schnell sehr viel wärmer und die
Temperaturen sind sehr sehr extrem so
extrem dass Elektronik unter diesen
Temperatur nicht funktionieren kann es
sei denn sie ist in einem geheizten Raum
untergebracht
Idefix ist ein Deutsch Franzose in enger
Kooperation des deutschen luft- und
raumfahrtzentrums und der französischen
Raumfahrtagentur sinenes entwickelt und
gebaut in Deutschland waren DLR
Institute in Bremen Berlin und
Oberpfaffenhofen beteiligt den Weltraum
TÜV bekam idfix in toulous
funktionaltests
vibrationstests thermal und vakuumtests
sowie einen Test auf elektromagnetische
Verträglichkeit hat der Rover gut
überstanden insgesamt acht
wissenschaftliche Geräte müssen im Bauch
von edefix Platz finden der Rover ist
randvoll gepackt mit
Technologie da muss ein vollwertiger
Computer drin sein der Bilder
komprimieren kann der Sensoren a lesen
kann es sind wissenschaftsinstrumente
drin es sind vier Kameras drin es muss
eine Versorgungseinheit drin sein die
letztendlich die Solarpanele nüzt um die
Batterie zu laden es muss die Batterie
geladen werden
all diese
Dinge wir brauchen die Motoren für die
die Schultern der der Beine wir brauchen
die Motoren für die Räder das ganze Ding
ist von oben bis unten voll Technik hier
oben haben wir noch eine Antenne wir
haben hier haben wir den
Sonnensensor da ist kein Platz mehr drin
ein wichtiges wissenschaftliches
Instrument wurde in Berlin gebaut das
Radiometer es soll helfen herauszufinden
um welches Material es sich auf fobus
handelt unser Radiometer kann
Oberflächentemperaturen Messen in sechs
spektralen Kanälen und man sieht hier
die sechs verschiedenen Aperturen
jeweils mit einzelnen Sensoren
ausgestattet und wir können damit
besonders tiefe Temperaturen auf der
phobosoberfläche Messen Temperaturen bis
zu
-150° wir werden also mit idfix ein
Objekt das uns interessiert Anfahren
dort einen ganzen vobosag lang die
Temperatur messen und dann aus den
Temperaturschwankungen die
thermophysikalischen Eigenschaften
extrahieren die primären Daten sind
natürlich die Temperaturdaten die wir
mit unserem Radiometer aufnehmen aber
daraus ableiten können wir auch
Materialeigenschaften also die
Wärmeleitfähigkeit des Materials und
auch die
Porosität das zweite in Berlin gebaute
Instrument ist ein Spektrometer ein
winzig kleines Messgerät das dennoch
robust der Weltraumstrahlung widersteht
gehen muss um seine Aufgaben der
Materialbestimmung auf pobus zu erfüllen
die technischen Augen und Ohren von
Idefix meinen die Wissenschaftler schmun
sind das ist ein Sinnesorgan von Idefix
es ist nicht direkt vergleichbar mit
unserem menschlichen Sinnesorgan ist
viel mehr es ist so als wenn wir noch
noch mehr Geschmacksnerven hätten oder
noch ganz andere Sachen sehen
könnten wir haben da an Bord ein kleinen
Laser winzig kleinen speziall Laser der
schießt auf die Oberfläche ein Stück des
Lichts kommt zurück und wir analysieren
die Qualität dieses Lichts also welche
Frequenz hat das wie schnell schwingt
das Licht und aus diesen Schwingungen
können wir sagen da ist ein Mineral a
oder Mineral B Marsmond fobus könnte
viel Erkenntnis über die Entstehung
unseres Planetensystems bringen wenn das
japanische mutterraumschiff auf dem Mond
landet hat
idfix mit seinen Daten geholfen die
Landestellen zur Probenentnahme
auszuwählen von all diesen Abenteuern im
Mars Universum erzählt Idefix den
interessierten Erdbewohnern auch im
Internet denn viele wünschen ihm
Glück mein größter Wunsch wäre dass
idifix es tatsächlich schafft auf die
Oberfläche zu kommen und sich
aufzurichten und uns die ersten Signale
zu schicken ich sag mal wenn wenn wir
das geschafft haben dann sind wir glaube
ich alle sehr sehr froh und sehr sehr
stolz wir wünschen uns natürlich dass
wir möglichst viel Strecke auf dem Mond
zurücklegen können s dass wir sehr
unterschiedliche Areale auf dem Mond
untersuchen können ich wünsche ihm
natürlich ein langes langes Leben und
ich wünsche ihm dass er seine Neugierde
erhält und wartt und ausbaut und viele
tolle Dinge für uns und mit uns entdeckt
wenn das mutterraumschiff mit der
Gesteinsprobe wieder startet bleibt der
kleine Mini Rover edefix auf fobus
zurück in einer Rückkehrkapsel wird nur
das Außerirdische Material vom phobus
zur Erde
geschickt wenn das gelingt könnte das
die allererste marsprobe auf unserer
Erde sein
ه